bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7 8 weekends vous le
savez en votre émission hebdomadaire
consacrée à l'actualité culture loisirs
et sport de la semaine et ce pendant 26
minutes comme tout les vendredis au
cours de ce numéro nous parlerons
court-métrage cette semaine avec la
web-série équation réalisée à Plaisir
l'équipe nous parlera de ce projet vidéo
qui cartonne sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis quelques semaines nous
consacrerons également une large au
spectacle qui auront lieu sur tous
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines dans les jours
et semaines qui suivront évidemment vous
le savez tous vos agendas et vos
rendez-vous de votre weekend mais tout
d'abord place à notre page spéciale
cinéma
sortie il y a un petit peu plus d'un
mois le premier épisode de la web série
équation tournée à Plaisir faites un
carton sur les réseaux sociaux Facebook
YouTube évidemment les raisons de ce
succès on va les évoquer avec l'équipe
du tournage et donc d'équation en
présence sur le plateau de ce 7 8
weekends on va commencer à ma droite
donc Jean-Philippe Martin le scénariste
bonjour à vous vous êtes accompagné de
votre comédienne Camille Breteil bonjour
à vous merci d'être là et le réalisateur
James seven bonjour à vous merci à tous
les trois d'être présents alors ce
projet tout d'abord première question un
petit peu de curiosité comment est né
équation
alors c'est à dire qu'en fait l'idée à
l'origine vient de James voilà donc il
avait dans l'idée de créer une web série
concentré sur la ville de plaisir parce
qu'il est originaire de la vie de
plaisir et
apparemment il cherchait une personne
pour écrire justement l'histoire et via
facebook en fait on s'est retrouvé sur
sur une page commune qui s'appelle tu
sais que tu viens de plaisir quand trois
petits points c'est un peu une page à la
mode en ce moment et d'ailleurs c'est
Jam qui a créé cette page et donc il a
vu que sur ce site j'avais fait un petit
peu de pub en fait parce que bon j'ai un
petit peu d'expérience dans l'écriture
j'ai écrit un bouquin que j'ai publié et
donc via Facebook et il a vu que j'avais
déjà écrit donc il m'a contacté alors
sur l'histoire de d'équation et puis de
cette web série j'aime un peu expliquer
nous sans trop nous vous en dévoiler
mais un petit peu le concept de la web
série mais en fait nous on a pris le
risque de faire de pas faire une comédie
justement voilà de faire un truc sérieux
intrigant un peu de suspense avec voilà
des rebondissements et voilà ça se passe
comme ça en fait ça va être un peu plus
angoisse suspense voilà pour justement
le découvrir un petit peu plus en images
ce que cela donne je vous propose de
regarder un petit extrait et on en parle
encore un peu plus après
alors évidemment sur les images que vous
venez de voir ce n'était pas Camille
Breteil qui était dans ce premier
épisode c'est un petit peu aussi la
raison de votre venue aujourd'hui c'est
l'actualité de la web-série justement
pourquoi Camille est présente
aujourd'hui avec vous alors voilà ce
qu'on voulait ce qu'on voulait annoncer
en fait aux personnes qui nous suivent
déjà un petit peu sur Facebook il faut
savoir que on est suivi par presque
enfin pratique un peu plus de 500
personnes sur le sur facebook donc ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que à la suite
de la diffusion du premier épisode
la comédienne donc qui incarnait le
premier rôle a dû nous abandonner parce
qu'elle avait un projet un peu plus
intéressant de son côté et donc de là on
s'est retrouvé un petit peu dans
l'embarras il a fallu qu'on trouve une
autre solution donc on a pesé le pour le
contre de savoir s'il fallait retourner
un premier épisode avec une nouvelle
comédienne ou alors si on pouvait
enchaîner sur un deuxième épisode et je
trouve qu'on a opté pour la première
solution parce que la deuxième semblait
très difficile au niveau de la
réalisation de de la deuxième épisode
prochain épisode et donc on avait casté
Camille au tout début pour un autre rôle
dans la série et naturellement on s'est
tourné vers elle quand il a fallu qu'on
trouve une personne pour jouer le
premier rôle et justement Camille quand
vous avez été approché par ce duo si
vous avez tout de suite dit oui pour ce
premier rôle tout de suite pour qu'elle
raison c'est quelque chose qui vous
attire tout ce qui est court-métrage etc
tout ce qui est l'univers du cinéma
l'univers du théâtre c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours plu et déjà quand j'ai
pris connaissance de l'histoire c'est
quelque chose qui m'a intéressé tout de
suite et quand on m'a proposé de
récupérer le premier rôle tout de suite
enfin j'ai même pas hésité une seconde
c'est j'ai dit oui après j'ai dû faire
mes preuves pour que qu'ils aient
confiance en moi un essai évidemment
comment vous le voyez justement votre
votre rôle dans cette web série
qu'est-ce que vous allez incarner qui
allez-vous incarner justement c'est un
peu
c'est un peu flou c'est quelqu'un qui se
connaît pas elle-même donc j'ai pas
encore perçu complètement le personnage
c'est quelqu'un qui se réveille donc
dans une forêt qui a plus du tout
conscience de qui elle est et donc elle
va parcourir plusieurs plusieurs chemins
pour se retrouver et puis je le fais
avec elle en même temps ça va être
évidemment une expérience enrichissante
j'imagine au niveau personnel alors
cette histoire de cette web série elle
est aussi particulière parce que bah
tout ce qui est montage etc se fait dans
un quartier de plaisir c'est ça j'aime
exactement oui donc il y a une
association de plaisir du valibu qui
nous a aidé pour nous prêter une salle
si c'est le mieux vivre value voilà donc
il nous a prêté un local dans le
valibout donc on peut se regrouper faire
nos castings aussi dans la salle c'est
un petit peu en mode système d où vous
êtes quand même assez
alors c'est à dire qu'en fait au tout
début il faut savoir qu'on a passé
plusieurs castings on a fait cinq
séances de casting et on a la chance
d'avoir un ami dans les contacts de
James qui tient un petit restaurant sur
le quartier du bas du Boo qui s'appelle
le Tombouctou et qui nous a
gracieusement prêté les lieux pour nos
castings filmés donc ça c'était vraiment
super ça nous a bien aidé et ensuite
James a réussi à obtenir un local de la
part de cette association où on était un
peu plus à l'étroit où on pouvait
vraiment apporter l'ordinateur faire nos
montages sur place plus concentrer nos
activités sur ce lieu et alors pour
revenir concrètement sur le schéma de
cette web-série racontez-nous vraiment
un petit peu l'histoire sans trop
dévoiler la fin évidemment mais de ce de
web série équation alors ce qui se passe
donc dans les dans l'extrait qu'on a vu
on voit que la comédienne se réveille
avec un peu de mal elle trouve à sa
gauche une seringue on se rend pas bien
compte maintenant mais la seringue a été
utilisée donc elle va se rendre compte
se rendre compte après qu'elle a été en
fait réveillé par la seringue et
à l'instant où elle va se mettre sur
pied elle va avoir dans l'idée de
retrouver son histoire retrouver son
passé et
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est qu'elle
va retrouver sur elle en téléphone
portable
qu'elle ne peut pas activer et qui ne
sonne uniquement quand on a quand on la
contact et donc il se trouve que quand
elle arrive à se dépatouiller un peu de
cette forêt le téléphone sonne et elle
va avoir un rendez-vous et en fait ce
rendez-vous une fois qu'elle va s'y
rendre elle va tomber sur une personne
qui est dans le même état qu'elle
endormi avec une seringue à côté et là
elle va se poser la question de savoir
si elle doit planter la seringue pour
réveiller la personne ou si c'est autre
chose qu'il y a dedans et qui risque de
tuer cette personne voilà elle va
prendre un risque et voilà des épisodes
dans l'épisode ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'il va avoir plusieurs personnes à les
réveiller un peu partout sans trop en
dire soit la rive à l'heure elle arrive
à le réveiller soit elle arrive trop
tard les personnes décèdent
et les personnes qui vont réussir à se
réveiller vont former en fait au final
le noyau dur de l'équation il va y avoir
plusieurs personnages principaux en fait
très bien on en sait déjà un petit peu
plus pour ceux qui vous suivent
évidemment de près sur ce de suite à ce
premier épisode et aussi il y a le ce
côté bénévole dans votre projet parce
que là en fin de compte vous ne touchez
pas voilà d'argent il y a pas il y a
aucun budget
indépendant tout à fait donc on investit
tout nous-même
on n'est pas payé évidemment on a on
sait notre travail à côté donc on
travaille à côté c'est plus une passion
à la base donc on était passionné on
fait ça pour pour le plaisir à la base
et pourquoi alors justement sur la ville
de plaisir ce tournage parce que
justement moi j'avais vu que j'avais
créé le groupe tu sais que tu viens de
plaisir quand et que et que avec les
gens du groupe ça se passait bien j'ai
créé un clip déjà voilà j'ai voulu
poursuivre l'aventure et et sortir un
peu du milieu de clip et de commencer à
faire un peu de web série voir un peu
comment comment ça se passe des
des choses un petit peu plus approfondie
exactement le seul problème que j'avais
c'était l'écriture donc maintenant que
j'ai un scénariste voilà il s'occupe de
l'écriture je m'occupe du montage et
pour filmer le duo et complémentaire et
alors dernière question évidemment je
pense que beaucoup attendent parce qu'il
y a quand même eu près de 2000 vues déjà
sur ce premier épisode le deuxième
épisode à quand et ben pour tout vous
dire en fait l'épisode 2 a été
entièrement tourné il est à 90% monté il
est presque diffusé donc on va se
laisser un petit peu le temps de
peaufiner notre travail et on peut
espérer enfin vous on vous annonce une
sortie pour la fin du mois de janvier
très bien on suivra ça de près merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'être passé
sur ce journal et donc évidemment
rendez-vous fin janvier pour ce deuxième
épisode on reste dans le cinéma et vous
le savez comme toutes les semaines on
jette un petit coup d'oeil sur les sales
obscures cette semaine c'est Gaëlle
Pinault du grenier à sel à Trappes qui
vous délivre son coup de cœur
bonjour et bonne année je voudrais vous
parler d'un autre film coup de cœur de
cette semaine il s'agit du film Chantons
sous la pluie qui est une comédie
musicale sur l'histoire du cinéma il a
été tourné en 1953 en couleur en
technicolor donc des couleurs très très
chatoyantes c'est un film fondateur
puisque il est il était dans 1953 mais
il raconte le début du cinéma parlant
les années 30 avec le cinéma muet et
l'arrivée du parlant c'est l'histoire de
downlo coude et Lina le monde qui sont
deux stars du cinéma muet hollywoodien
et le cinéma parlant arrive et là ils
vont devoir s'adapter et malheureusement
le la voie désagréable de Lina va
menacer le duo et on engage alors Cathy
qui est une danseuse pour
pour doubler la voix de Nina alors c'est
intéressant puisque sur pendant les
passages de tournage de film muet on
voit que sur le même plateau on peut
avoir plusieurs tournages en même temps
puisque le son ne dérange pas on entend
tout le monde qui crie à droite à gauche
mais vu que le son il passe pas c'est
c'est assez intéressant d'avoir ça on a
vraiment l'histoire du cinéma et puis on
a tout le processus de création du film
du film parlant avec les problèmes
techniques qui pouvaient avoir à
l'époque où est-ce qu'on met le micro
comment ça marche est-ce qu'on tourne la
tête est-ce que le micro il prend bien
le son c'est très intéressant c'est
vraiment très beau puis il y a c'est un
film de chant de danse de claquettes
c'est un film sur l'histoire du cinéma
encore une fois qu'il y a deux séances
de ce film là une en version française
une en version originale sous-titrée
vous retrouvez ces séances sur notre
site
www.cinemagrandyacel.com merci
et si vous ne savez pas quoi aller voir
dans les prochains jours voici quelques
avis éclairés des spectateurs au micro
dès le 10 moines
j'ai pensé que c'était une fille une
réalité un bon film parce que je
connaissais cette affaire à l'âge de
tous les jours de avant et donc je
trouvais que c'était c'est triste
comment faire très bien très réaliste
bon je connaissais pas du tout l'affaire
c'était sympa tu as un film très prenant
et je suis commellement bouleversée par
ce film là sachant qu'il risque de
libérer en 2020 ça fait un peu peur
c'est un très bon film très bon acteur
ça a bien été filmé mais c'est prenant
mais j'ai passé un moment agréable j'ai
apprécié tous les rôles enfin j'ai
trouvé un film divertissant
avec beaucoup de décorations j'ai trouvé
ça super Vincent Rotier déjà j'adore
donc je suis venu pour lui
et tous les acteurs sont vraiment
splendides vraiment super j'ai trouvé ça
assez extraordinaire très touchant et je
savais pas du tout en fait de quoi ça
parlait enfin j'en avais entendu parler
vite fait mais je connaissais pas
vraiment le sujet du film tout et donc
je trouve ça vraiment super
et on enchaîne comme promis avec notre
page spéciale spectacle et je vous
propose de nous intéresser à un opéra
film Mitsu un vrai challenge artistique
qui est proposé le 23 janvier prochain
au Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
à la recherche du temps perdu avec
Jean-charles Fitoussi et Claire Mélanie
Seigneur
un orchestre un film des acteurs doublés
par des chanteurs c'est le principe d'un
opéra film un concept novateur proposait
le 23 janvier sur la scène du théâtre de
50 ans en Yvelines au manette un duo
d'artistes qui a travaillé pendant une
année lui est réalisateur elle et
musicienne ils ont d'abord réalisé un
film autour du thème d'une lettre de
rilkee au peintre Balthus avant de
passer à la conception musicale tout un
challenge
on a tourné un film en sachant que ça
allait être mis en musique et surtout
que les acteurs du film allaient être
doublés par les chanteurs d'opéra
et du coup on a tourné le film d'une
manière un peu différente de celle que
nous aurions utilisé si on avait tourné
un film normal c'est à dire que je
dirigeais les acteurs de telle sorte que
la compositrice puisse ensuite écrire sa
musique qui s'articulerait avec les
paroles des acteurs parfois on leur
faisait des prises plus lentes plus
rapides pour quel est le un peu plus le
choix disons du tempo de sa musique
le compositeur est tout le temps face à
des contraintes et heureusement pour lui
parce que sinon n'a pas le le le
l'aspect infini des possibles et
vertigineux donc je dirais là évidemment
la contrainte on la connaissait
puisqu'on a on avait choisi ce
dispositif ensemble
et que du coup au contraire j'étais très
contente de savoir que j'allais avoir un
contrat je ne savais pas comment
j'allais m'en dépêtrer il a fallu
choisir les prises et ensuite relever
les rythmiques qui à partir de là
complètement imaginé la musique qui
allait accompagné ça les notes qu'elle
allait être chanter le travail donc de
près d'une année à découvrir le 23
janvier vous pourrez y suivre le
parcours d'un enfant qui en cherchant
son chat Mitsu trouve la porte du temps
si en gouffre pour mieux retrouver son
animal de compagnie un conte plein de
magie qui dure une heure environ à voir
en famille
et on reste sur les planches avec la
pièce de théâtre de William Shakespeare
tempête cette comédie tragique raconte
un petit peu l'histoire du duc de Milan
exilé sur une île déserte qui va
retrouver son trône en renonçant à la
magie en chef d'orchestre Alain Pralon
société honoraire de la Comédie
Française représentation donnée ce
samedi soir au prisme d'Élancourt à 21h
tarif à partir de 21 euros un petit
extrait
pourquoi vous avez provoqué cette
tempête seulement pour l'instant que la
généreuse fortune qui maintenant me
sourit ajouter mes ennemis sur ce rival
et seul au moment même où ma science
très voir si je sais d'accueillir sans
attendre qu'une étoile peut mettre à
favorable faire des criminer mon
danse à présent et du hip-hop plus
précisément le groupe justement de
hip-hop les Pokémon crew sont de passage
à la Merise attrape ce week-end laissait
danseurs rendre hommage notamment au
cinéma des années 40 première
chorégraphie dimanche à partir de 16
heures un petit extrait
avant de passer au sport dernier
rendez-vous de spectacle pour votre
week-end il s'agit de pixels présenté un
au théâtre de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
jusqu'au 10 janvier et mise en scène par
Mourad Merzouki une exploration
artistique pour le moins très riche
allez pour ce premier 7 8 weekends de
l'année 2015 dernier coup de rétroviseur
de dans les 12 derniers mois de 2014
avec la rétro des meilleurs moments
sport au montage romain
on a travaillé dur cette année c'est le
fruit de 10 entrailles je suis très fier
de ça
on aura l'occasion de se côtoyer
d'échanger nos expériences et ça quand
on veut aller chercher une médaille aux
Jeux Olympiques tous ces petits détails
là ça compte
avoir nous aussi réussi à battre le
précédent alors on n'a pas le meilleur
temps mondial parce que les filles sont
les plus vite que nous en finale mais
c'est vraiment une grande satisfaction
c'est une belle histoire j'espère
qu'elle va continuer parce que on va
partir dans une nouvelle aventure il y
aura quelques étapes à franchir mais on
va savourer quand même ces petits
moments là
aujourd'hui c'était une bonne journée je
ne m'attendais pas à gagner j'ai
beaucoup de chance d'être assis à côté
de ce trophée
les moyens
sincèrement qui aurait pu miser une
pièce sur nous mais bon voilà c'est un
groupe qui travaille dur toute la saison
on a invaincu en championnat c'est que
de récompense par rapport à tout ce
qu'on travaille depuis 3 ans
en mars prochain elles enclencheront la
première de leurs 4x4 destinations les
dunes et le désert marocain après avoir
bouclé leur budget de yvelinoises Alice
et Sandrine continuent leur préparation
pour le Rallye des Gazelles 2015 nous
les avons suivies lors de leur stage de
pilotage reportage réalisé avec Florent
parfait
le levier de vitesse semble parfois
capricieux mais chaque minute passait à
bord de leur 4x4 et pleine
d'enseignements après avoir bouclé leur
budget en vue de leur participation
Rallye des Gazelles 2015 Alice et
Sandrine effectuent ce jour-là un stage
de pilotage si pour l'instant l'équipage
ne pratique pas le sable mais plutôt la
bouffe francilienne cette session
conduite permet au rambolitaine de
découvrir leur véhicule pour le moment
le vit très bien on découvre des
nouvelles sensations on découvre notre
4x4 que l'on a utilisé qu'une seule fois
la semaine dernière pour le moment et on
apprécie ces nouvelles sensations de
glissade on se demande si on va passer
mais ça passe souvent
nos vies sont rallyes il leur faudra
parcourir 2500 km et surtout résister
neuf jours dans l'enfer des dunes
marocaines car dans le Rallye des
Gazelles la navigation se fait à
l'ancienne sans GPS si Sandrine n'est
plus à l'aise avec carte et boussole et
Alice au volant chacune prend ses
repères à tous les postes avant la
course quand on a besoin encore on a
encore besoin de préparation il faut
concentrer le véhicule va être
immobilisé pendant un mois pour pour la
déco intérieure extérieure
faut qu'on reprenne en mois de février
faut qu'on prenne un peu les
entraînements parce que même si je pense
qu'on se débrouille pour l'instant pas
trop mal on est encore pas sûr de nous
et il faut qu'on
s'entraîne encore
prochain étape un stage de navigation
fin janvier pour apprendre les bases
d'une carte et d'un compas avant le
départ pour le Maroc le 25 mars prochain
avant de refermer ce journal place au
rendez-vous sport du week-end et les
matchs à ne pas rater tout d'abord du
football féminin Division d'Honneur 6e
journée décalé Montigny reçoit l'équipe
réserve de Juvisy l'équipe
professionnelle qui évolue en Division 1
coup d'envoi à 16h ce samedi 10 janvier
au stade de la cool du rugby au
programme également fédéral de 11e
journée plaisir reçoit le quatrième
Nantes à Robert baron ce dimanche 11
janvier coup d'envoi à 15h pour tenter
de décrocher une belle troisième
victoire de leur saison et débuter 2015
de la meilleure des façons pour les
plaisirs rois c'est la fin de ce 7 8
week-end merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend sur tvfils à très
bientôt